Some YouTube creators are upset that YouTube is automatically demonetizing certain video game videos
with its machine-learning algorithm.
The suggested explanation is the depiction of guns, though YouTube denies this.
Gamers who previously made money on the platform
now find their revenue drying up.
In the big picture, the issue is about how
to fund content and its delivery.
Now, gamers or game companies could make their own platform and charge a fee for users to participate,
but many prefer advertising-funded content rather than paying out-of-pocket.
The trouble is that advertising dollars are increasingly concentrated with
a few ad platforms.
Unfortunately, this trend has been strengthened in part by the FCC's Title II net neutrality rules, which block
game makers and gamers from finding alternative models for advertising, particularly from their ISP.
In the meantime, we should welcome the emergence
of alternative platforms Patreon and
Twitch, but we also need more diversity in the business
models to bring competition to the concentrated
ad platform market.
Removing the FCC’s net neutrality
rules is a step in the right direction.
To learn more about my take on tech policy,
check the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you want our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.